because in the past in the 1950s and and
before that
like it was it was okay to be
hypergamous in a way because women
didn't really have much money so if a
guy makes uh I don't I don't know like
by those standards 30k a year that was
fine because they they were they were
still living with their parents but now
like women actually out earn men in many
in in certain industry I'm not sure but
I know that they go to college more than
than men do and so they want a man
that's more educated they want a man
that makes more money and like
realistically given their nature that
makes sense get due to history but it
doesn't make sense now because men and
women are competing and their standards
aren't lowering